Boris Johnson will return to work on
Monday three weeks after being taken
into intensive care with Kovac 19 the
prime minister who's been recovering in
checkers
since being discharged from hospital is
said to be raring to go
it comes as the government denies there
have been mixed messages over the
lockdown today the number of people
who've died in UK hospitals with kovat
19 was confirmed to have passed 20,000
and the number of people killed with the
virus around the world is now more than
200,000 well Sky's chief husband John
Craig joins us now from Downing Street
so John doctors have given Boris Johnson
the green light to get back to work and
he has some key decisions to make the
big decision of course is the mounting
pressure over the lockdown and whether
to ease it when to ease it all the
details and so on the medical bulletin
from the on the Prime Minister is very
encouraging it's let's not forget he
spent seven nights in since Hamas's
hospital including three in intensive
care when he came out he said it could
have gone either way that was his phrase
it's about a fortnight since he left
hospital he's been recovering at
Chequers we learned from President Trump
during the week that mr. Barratt mr.
Johnson was in good form and he was well
enough also the prime minister to have
an audience with the Queen the first for
three weeks now according to number ten
sources the Prime Minister has told
colleagues that he is raring to go and
will be back here on Monday he had a
checkers meeting with advisers on Friday
he'll be meeting the health secretary
Matt Hancock and getting back to his
normal schedule on Monday morning he was
updated on the progress being made in
the fight against coronavirus and was
given a detailed briefing on the work
being carried out on the fight against
the disease we're told and we're told
that this summit marked a tightening of
grip from
the Prime Minister who held a series of
calls and zoom meetings with key figures
throughout the week he also hosted a
daily video call with the Foreign
Secretary Dominic Rob who's been his
stand-in for the past few weeks and his
number 10 team at 3:00 p.m. every day
while he was at checkers and was briefed
on the latest plans he held lengthy
discussions with the chief medical
officer Chris Witte and the chief
scientific adviser Sir Patrick Valens
but he comes back with a real chorus of
calls from Conservative Party donors
cabinet colleagues and conservative
backbenchers senior backbenchers for an
easing of the lockdown this Sunday Times
is reporting that big party donors
Conservative Party donors are among
those demanding an easing of the
lockdown to boost the economy
so a lot riding on the next few days
there are those who claim that after his
a pretty serious illness three nights in
intensive care
that he of course knows better than
anybody else the threat from coronavirus
the government has been insisting that's
five tests have to be met from raising
ranging from the NHS his ability to cope
the first to the most serious of course
the risk of a second peak of the disease
and there are those who believe that mr.
Johnson because of his serious illness
will be less likely to back those
ministers including his next-door
neighbor the Chancellery she soon ak who
say look this is really crippling the
British economy we've got to ease the
lock down and so big decisions from the
Prime Minister first we may see him with
maybe the five o'clock news conference
here on Monday he may possibly do Prime
Minister's Questions against Labour's
new leader circus Tama but we can say
for certain he's back here on Monday
full schedule according to his who is in
a circle here and yes he's told
colleagues he's raring to go